at what point
uh
did you finally realize that they were
the two behind the whole thing
well after that first time uh
visiting them in the philippines which
is where they were running uh which is
where they were more or less running
their operations out of sort of a
mixture of the philippines and japan but
uh after that first trip i was like gosh
these guys
these guys are suspicious
you know you got the feeling right off
the bat
what's that you got the feeling right
off the bat
right off the bat yeah the way they were
answering questions the the
the
what they were what they were hiding
sort of the clues that were coming from
omission their knowledge base
the way they would interact
sometimes they would know too much
sometimes they would know too little
and i don't think that they were really
prepared for me that first time either
and their chores their stories
completely changed the next time i went
and filmed with them they they kind of
recalibrated it would seem behind the
scenes which is also what someone who
was working for their organization
relayed to me
so
you know from that point on it became a
very much a kind of cat and mouse game
with myself and with ron and with jim
you know and ron remained kind of
my top suspect until that summer
uh when
um he presented me with a pile of
forensic evidence that pointed to the
individual that he claimed was behind it
which ron said it was steve bannon and
that he'd known that it was steve bannon
since uh nearly the beginning and of
course steve bannon is uh you know
was sort of the architect of the 2016
trump campaign and sort of a master of
digital strategies so he's a he's a good
suspect if you're looking for a sure
yeah um so at that point i was like okay
well this is
this seems viable you know how did he
how did he put together this forensic
trail is it is it authentic or not was
it steve bannon or was it wrong you know
those were those became my top two
suspects and we really parsed out what
happened and why i think that happened
in the series ultimately i come to the
conclusion that um you know the whole
time ron was more or less larping as
steve bannon trying to say okay who
would be the right person to lead
someone like colin too and maybe he was
a little bit disappointed that
nobody had seen his awesome forensic
trail up until that point so uh you know
that's um that's the explanation that i
arrive at in the series
and uh
um
yeah
you know it was a very uh it was a very
credible trail you know
it uh
it pointed in his direction in a in a in
a way that was hard to
um hard to explain but i think we come
up with a good explanation
did steve mind being the person like did
that become public where people were
thinking it was steve behind the whole
thing
um
sorry say again did steve mind that
people accused him of being behind cue
you know i i don't i i reached out to
steve bannon and his um you know his uh
her personal handler multiple times i
was trying to get an interview with him
about this you know i eventually said
look it looks like someone's trying to
trying to set you up kind of as the fall
guy for q
um you know
they he was actually open to talking
with me about q anon not because he was
necessarily involved in it but just
because he was interested in the topic
and that just never came to fruition but
i don't know exactly what uh what his
feelings are on at this point i don't
know um since the election of ron
watkins and and steve bannon are talking
i know that ron had been trying over the
course of
maybe many years to get in touch with
steve bannon and that's one of the
things that you see in the series this
idea of me magic of something starting
as just a game or a larp and becoming
real you know
sort of pretending to have the cue
pretending to have access to the um
upper the upper echelon of government
the
the inside circle of trump and then by
the end of the series you see that ron
and and those in his orbit actually do
get that access
um and so you know in the year that's
kind of followed you say well you know
is ron in touch with steve bannon now um
you know he was advising in those later
days on on
election fraud uh issues so
uh i mean it's it's a
it's an unbelievable exercise in in kind
of will to power i guess so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]